and finally new rule Republicans have to
admit they don't just hate Democrats
they hate democracy they hate the player
and the game
this is a real picture of Mitch
McConnell last week
after he won the vote against hearing
from witnesses at Trump's impeachment
trial that's his Oh face so stop saying
Republicans don't have principles they
do they are deeply committed to all
things undemocratic get this week get
this last week the deep red conservative
counties of Virginia threatened to
secede and join West Virginia creating a
new state called fat Sylvania
Jerry Falwell Jr longtime Virginia
resident and second-generation religious
conman said many counties in Virginia
are taking a long hard look at escaping
the barbaric totalitarian and corrupt
democratic regime Wow
totalitarian barbaric why because
Virginia had an election and the
Democrats won we we used to call that an
orderly transition of power and Patriots
don't secede they stay and participate
as the loyal opposition a few years ago
a Republican chair of North Carolina's
redistricting committee said I think
electing republicans is better than
electing Democrats so I drew the map to
help foster what I think is better for
the country Wow they don't even think
they should play fair it's why they love
the Electoral College and are constantly
inventing new forms of voter suppression
the Republican view is you have the
right to vote unless you're likely to
vote for Democrats in which case we
reserve the right to cheat to stop you
in 2016 when Supreme Court Justice
Scalia died Mitch McConnell said since
the seat had become vacant in an
election year this Senate would not even
consider a nomination from Obama which
he found in article 1 section 4 of his
ass
Mitch said even though I know the
Constitution is clear that when the
Supreme Court's lot comes open the
sitting president gets to fill it and
it's my job as a senator to make that
happen that's the old America a nation
of laws we're living in the new America
with only one law make me make me you
know when a country slides into
authoritarian rule you don't get a text
alert things will look the same on the
surface the busses will still be running
the cops will still be patrolling you
can still get your hair done your
favorite show was still on TV unless
maybe it's this one
[Applause]
Americans are always worried that when
we lose our freedom it'll look like the
movie Red Dawn with tanks in the streets
that's not how our republic ends we keep
the names on the institution's we just
change what's inside
we still have trials we just don't have
witnesses and you still subpoena people
they just don't show up they're still an
EPA it just works for the coal companies
now it's like the way TV channels
sometimes completely change format but
keep the name MTV music television
hasn't had music videos for years the
Learning Channel has no learning the
learning channel has honey booboo and
America's worst tattoos and family by
the ton that's us now when Rome stopped
being a republic it didn't stop having a
Senate and neither have we
it's just more like student government
now because that's what dictators do
Russia has a pretend Parliament so does
China and North Korea just about every
week here I ask some Democrat what's the
plan for dealing with this new paradigm
that I believe we're already living in
and invariably they just laugh it off
here's mayor Pete last week you win but
Trump says there irregularities and he
can't give up the office what do you do
well it's gonna be a little awkward when
Chaston and I are moving into the White
House but and I like Pete I'm a big fan
and I'm glad he sort of won Iowa
but this is not funny things are so bad
what I've been thinking lately is the
fact that Bernie Sanders controls an
angry mob is actually a positive because
at least Sanders people will fight don't
fight Hillary but it's a start
you